areas devastated by Hurricane Florence
faced a major new threat today amid
rising water levels severe flooding is
reported all over the Carolinas and rain
is still falling in some places a major
city is isolated in the flood risk it
extends 250 miles from the coast
florence has killed at least 17 people
some areas have received more than 30
inches of rain since Thursday North
Carolina officials report more than 900
water rescues across the state think
about that this morning flood watch use
watches and warnings stretch all the way
to Pennsylvania where the remains of
Florence are headed these pictures from
Fayetteville show how difficult it is to
move around DeMarco Morgan is 40 miles
south in Pembroke North Carolina the
rescuers have been working non-stop for
days
DeMarco good morning good morning to you
Pembroke is just one of the many
communities that authorities have spent
the past couple of days searching for
residents stranded by floodwaters in the
rain has stopped at least for now but
now authorities are keeping a close eye
on levees and rivers that are now under
pressure all eyes are in Lumberton North
Carolina this morning where the rising
lumber river threatens to worsen
flooding relentless rain from Florence
caused the river to swell rising
overnight to more than 24 feet in an
already inundated city emergency
officials and volunteers have been
working around the clock to keep the
river at bay as Florence raged Friday
they frantically sandbagged a section of
the city where floodwaters from
Hurricane matthew had rushed in two
years ago as you can see the sandbags
did not work this is the lumber River
which is headed toward town as it did to
in Hurricane Matthew
with water levels on the rise the
priority is getting people out the so
called Keysha Navy a volunteer rescue
team from Louisiana helped evacuate
dozens stranded at a nursing facility in
Lumberton that dam a few miles away in
Pembroke firefighters raced Sunday to
rescue people trapped in homes
surrounded by water ahead of more rain
Jessica Locklear and her two young
children were rescued as floodwaters
started creeping into their home I can't
swim and I don't want my babies to drown
the firefighters are joined by local
volunteers struggling through
treacherous conditions you check it out
there with small boat you're putting
your life in the other person like a
danger to the north parts of downtown
Fayetteville are under water and could
be even more submerged when the Cape
Fear River is expected to crest later
this week around 62 feet now they told
my the rivers ain't Chris digit so when
they press this is really gonna get
serious authorities also keeping a close
eye on the Hope Mills dam that's near
Fayetteville after concerns overnight
that it may fail and more than half a
million people in both South and North
Carolina are without power and it could
take a couple of weeks before power is
fully restored Brianna and as you
mentioned water is expected to continue
to rise in the days ahead DeMarco thank
you